ja das mache ich hoffen wir noch auf
platz acht da bist durch lediglich
gefunden kommen würde wo ich meine neue
höhen bis zuletzt darauf etwas was ich
noch nie gesehen habe
was ist da bitte rat hat mich schlagen
aber wie was ist denn hier also guck mal
hier ist meine hohen kessel moment wo
herum
also ich habe schon alles abgegrast das
irgendwie wertvoll aussah oder ganz
einfach mal reingucken
das portal gun das quintett okay ich hab
schon bedeutet ja okay was kannst du
mich zur ersten höhlen gäste führen
ja ich will erst einmal ganz kurz oder
auguste dass uns noch nicht einmal ganz
runter gruppen hatte
reinschauen ersten starts oder sowie
hinzu toll wertvoll glaub ich
ich bin fest ich bin fast total damit
herum zu laufen ist wieder gefasst ich
bin fast tot
ich darf mich damit rumgespielt ihre
notizen mich nie wieder mitgespielt
rumlaufen ok ich jetzt oben zur
kissinger ich weiß auch wo die kiste ist
die 72 meter von mir entfernt ganz tief
runter gefallen ich sehe ja nicht jemand
ich sehe dem lachen und durch will dass
du dir gefunden ich mich eine halbe ist
sich da in diese situation wird das
unterfangen müssen sagt es war sehr gut
alter pu so meine lieben freunde ist es
gerade irgendetwas abgestürzt und ihr
habt wahrscheinlich viele sache nicht
mitbekommen wie zum beispiel dass ich
noch eine menge gefahren hab ich hab nur
diamanten bekomme ich weiß ich habe das
alles gesehen habt ihr noch mal habt
wenn die ganze familie und jäger saved
hier allgemein in diesem raum
ich habe nun diese ganzen sachen
jemanden den wir haben ist es eigentlich
gedacht dass wir es nach hause laufen
werden und die sachen werden und ein
aufnahmestopp machen werden allerdings
ist meine aufnahme abgekratzt deswegen
fasse ich euch das ganz kurz zusammen
ihr könnt die verpassten teil 1 verboten
gespielt nachgucken aus seiner sicht
anhalt wir nehmen das immer beide auf
wird für uns jetzt ein bisschen schwer
mit dem schneiden wie wir das alles
genau timen werden
aber ich denke das sollte kein problem
sein und in den nächsten folgen werden
uns dann einfach darum kümmern dass wir
dann von ihr nach hause kommen und dann
habe ich auch wieder mehr speicher so
freunde ich hoffe das rad verstand was
ich da gesagt habe und zwar fast ich
euch das noch mal ganz kurz zusammen
weil das alles ein bisschen hektisch
grad zusammengefasst bei uns war es mir
die aufnahme ungefähr bei keine ahnung
wie viel minuten beziehungsweise stunde
abgekratzt als ich den diamanten holen
wollte ich habe dann den diamanten
geholt denn dann hoch gelaufen habe
meine ganzen sachen von der kiste die
ich hatte zur kiste darüber geschleppt
und hab dann dort bemerkte sich dann
kurz mal wieder auf die extorre geschaut
habe dass das ganze abgestürzt ist hab
dann nachher geschaut okay gut jetzt wie
viel speicher hatte noch 30 gb denkt
okay 30 gigabyte ist eigentlich relativ
viel sechs tore machen das innerhalb von
30 sekunden voll deswegen weil die szene
gerade relativ kurz und wir haben uns
dann einfach gedacht ja ok dieser part
ist bei mir jetzt zwar kurz wie immer
also zehn minuten lang allerdings bei
uns
gespielt ist dieser part 30 minuten lang
dort könnt ihr einfach die fehlenden
sache nachkommen aus seiner perspektive
oder erwartet dann einfach bis auf die
nächste folge war es eigentlich nichts
besonderes inhalt und zur kiste gelaufen
die sachen zum der anderen kiste darüber
geschleppt was besonderes ich hoffe nur
ich hatte dass sie dir trotzdem gefallen
dann könnt ihr gerne eine positive
bewertung da lassen und dann würde ich
sagen geht es dann morgen um 19.30
normal weiter mit dem nächsten part
ich hoffe dass jetzt alles verstanden
hab einfach nur ein paar sachen verpasst
aber das ist nicht allzu schlimm
schaut einfach weiter das projekt an und
dann beschäftigen uns auch sehr bald
endlich mit feed the beast spezifischen
sachen und zwar merkel sagen er gesagt
dass wir uns erst mal ein haus bauen
wollen eine farm et cetera zu dass
grundlegende generell in minecraft man
immer brauchen und uns dann alle edith
ihren orten mit fcb sachen beschäftigen
die werden sicher wird es jetzt ganz
verstanden was ich euch jetzt mal sagen
wollte ist alles sehr kompliziert wird
es beim nächsten mal